it's Kardashian ketchup time first up a  happy birthday Saint West Kim K's  youngest turned a one-year-old on Monday  his aunts Kylie and Kendall Jenner  parties the weekend away in Miami the  unreleased sexy new projects literally  always wanted to do this I'm really  excited to show you  I asked Terry Richardson to do this with  me Kylie teased her first ever calendar  on snapchat while Kendall sizzled in  love magazine's annual advent calendar  project  [Music]  meanwhile Khloe Kardashian documented  getting her moles and freckles lasered  off and their soon-to-be sister-in-law  blac Chyna also got her sexy on posing  in a lacy lingerie for a new net  campaign